eu chamei o pessoal aqui pra ir para os
pés na capital
é complicado eu vou fazer aqui uma uma
passagem o bayern na outra perna com
cuidado o que afecta o que eu passei
para o tupi conectar um pouco em baixo
há alguns dias atrás tenha muito pelo o
que comer
[Música]
o sol se junta mais um vídeo e hoje eu
vou ensinar como fazer uma arma que o
fiz ela pensar no armênio viu o filme
percebe pães quer fazer algo mais ou
menos por cima aí com vocês acabaram de
ver a arma vai subindo e quando chega a
altura máxima aquela parte do tambor
começa a girar e ao mesmo tempo que
elogia começa a disparar elásticos para
frente para que os vírus é um sistema
hidráulico bastante simples formado por
duas seringas depois tento de 40
conectá-la e para vocês comprarem é só
ir a uma farmácia como el viejo
controlável e se temos barato que eu vou
comprar mais comprar um saco e por fazer
vários projectos hidráulicos mais para
frente
além disso precisar de políticos num dos
lados mas disse que grandes e vocês
conseguem comprar isso nas categorias e
uma embalagem acho que vai chegar para
você fazer um projeto todo olha que
coisa que vai ser mais difícil para esse
projeto é encontrar um motor que tem
alguma força ou seja um todo tem uma
caixa de produção na caixa do hotel que
são basicamente várias engrenagens que
vão rodando e transforma a velocidade
que vem aqui do motor em força neste
lado a cair mas se você não tiver em
casa podem comprar está online que está
mais ou menos de dois dólares a cair aí
claro todas as outras coisas mas isso é
o mais importante vocês tiverem isso o
resto vou encontrar em casa quase de
certeza é hora de começar a falar
[Música]
as luas manteigas neto assim
estou manco parecer pedindo quê
aifus plate
hilário escala
ayew nunes são eo que é da piada
[Música]
[Aplausos]
leva eye to eye extensa e flora
eu te explora o seu igual o meu 100% e
oi
love foi mais até 2015 day
[Música]
ae
e serv
não é
[Música]
só não guardar a dioe da ti
nem me smile a receita quilo de
ae possui do rio áreas causa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por isso são eu tinha bahia
descer
é de homens
assim
a desfilar de esgoto
o enredo que a escola viva e se obrigou
nem eu sei você e will i am one que foi
a cef 5 gay
[Música]
ae
[Aplausos]
ah
não tiro a shire a nua e esse rio
a escom que eu assine dill a num e hoje
[Música]
mora em lisboa
caminhos fez 11
o em alguma de infância é que esse bom
vem
ae
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
o 1 a 1
no fim eu espero que vocês tenham
gostado desse projeto é que eu só não
gostei muito e acho que é um brinquedo
bastante divertido que vocês fizerem
usem óculos de proteção que sejam
responsáveis e se tiver alguma sugestão
de algum projeto é só deixar os
comentários que depois as minhas ideias
o ponto aqui no filho especial que eu
tenho quase dez dias e mais para frente
eu vou fazer é isso muito obrigado
investido até brasil
o projeto ficha na parte final é feita
para o pessoal